It's Just Before Sunset that they set
off Brothers Nikola and Kalo jeromeo are
embarking on a nightly fishing trip but
they need to be mindful that there could
be others out there at large when we see
a boat we radio the coast guards and
then pass the coordinates if we see that
it's going too slow or about to sink we
stay we can't just leave them if they
are sinking we transport them but we
always need to get authorization first
taking on board migrants even in
distress is illegal
the boat sails south of lampedusa this
is the same route migrants take when
they set off from the shores of Tunisia
so the crew needs to be on alert because
in the dark small vessels could go
unnoticed there's a breeze the sea is
calm perfect weather conditions for
sailing but it's still hard to imagine
that in this dark vastness there are
people crammed in boats with no
navigation system trying to reach Italy
and not knowing if they will ever make
it on board there's always a little
apprehension as the crew pulls out their
net it was just a few months ago that
the skeleton was found still with some
clothes on many lampedus are refer to
the Mediterranean as the liquid
graveyard about 2 000 people have lost
their lives here so far this year
the first catch is modest
second one is better but there's a piece
of wood entangled in the net
from a migrant shipwreck says Nicola he
recognized it from the type of wood
it's a part of the hull
of course it's difficult it's dangerous
because the authorities save their lives
and leave their boats adrift we work at
night and it's easy to collide with
these boats also our Nets get damaged by
the ones at the bottom of the sea by 4
AM the radar signals about a few hundred
meters to our right but there's no light
the crew is sure it's a migrant boat
but they can't change the direction
we later found out that it could have
been this one that was a drift along the
same coordinates the Italian quarter de
finanza had reached them the water was
seeping in a disaster narrowly averted
more rescues happen throughout the night
as the sun rises the summer colors
emerge again tourists get ready for
another day in the sunshine unbeknownst
to them 350 people rescued at night were
making their way to the port while
hundreds of others were being relocated
Elsewhere on the mainland
Al Jazeera lampedusa